inflation ein echtes angst wort in
deutschland und tatsächlich schlägt
diese inflation gerade voll zu unser
alltag wird immer teurer strom gas
benzin wir berichten ihn seit tagen
darüber aber vor allem auch lebensmittel
wie zum beispiel kartoffeln butter
bezahlen für all das immer immer mehr
und unsere regierung die tut nur so als
würde sie jetzt so richtig dagegenhalten
sagt bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
schönen guten morgen & morgen warum
shooting nur so und mainz nicht richtig
ernst sagst du da bis jetzt sehen wir ja
überhaupt nix ist es nichts passiert und
es gibt zwei dinge und das ist eine
große heuchelei die wir da sehen zum
einen ist die regierung selbst
preistreiber wir sehen dass beim bauen
wir sehen dass beim wohnen gibt immer
neue vorschriften gibt höhere steuern
das heißt da wird es teurer gemacht wir
sehen es auch natürlich bei
energiepreisen beim tanken beim heizöl
beim gaza ist co2 abgabe obendrauf also
da macht die regierung bewusst dinge
teurer und dann gibt es in anderen punkt
sie kassiert natürlich gleichzeitig bei
der inflation noch kräftig mit akten von
einem liter benzin beispielsweise gehen
mittlerweile 90 cent als steuern und
abgaben an den staat das heißt je höher
auch die grundpreise sind wenn die
mehrwertsteuer oben drauf kommt umso
stärker ist das was beim
bundesfinanzminister bei olaf scholz in
die kasse fließt und deswegen ist
verständlich dass die regierung bisher
ganz ganz wenig eigentlich tut um diese
inflation die wir haben mit 4,1 prozent
wirklich zu dämpfen wie reagieren denn
jetzt unsere politiker auf die
inflationären bis jetzt ducken sich ganz
ganz viele weg aber wir haben auch
wirklich arroganz anfälle gerade bei der
spd vor kurzem sagte der
parteivorsitzende weiter norbert walter
borjans dass diese angst vor inflation
eigentlich unbegründet sag ich mal wir
haben den höchsten inflation stand den
höchsten preis seit 28 jahren und dann
hat sich gestern abend katarina barley
immerhin vize präsidentin des
europäischen parlaments geäußert und die
hat gesagt naja wenn strompreise zu hoch
sind dann ist doch die günstigste
kilowattstunde die die man nicht
verbraucht mit andern worten dann
verbraucht doch einfach weniger strom
gestern gefallen beim kollegen frank
plasberg am arm weil er hat aber fair da
war sie zu gast katarina barley und sie
sagt eben diesen satz die günstigste
kilowattstunde ist die liebe leute die
man nicht verbraucht eine
unverschämtheit als eine absolute
unverschämtheit denn es war auch gerade
die spd die ja zusammen mit rot grün
dazu beigetragen hat dass wir in
deutschland die höchsten strompreise in
europa haben einführung der ökostrom
umlage der sogenannten eeg-umlage
mittlerweile bei über 610 sollte damals
insgesamt nur eine kugel eis kosten pro
monat mittlerweile deutlich deutlich
teurer geworden also so gesehen was
treibt den preis und sagt ja wenn euch
das zu teuer ist dann verbraucht doch
einfach weniger strom ist natürlich der
effekt denen genau das jetzt haben
sollen vor allen dingen die über die
ganzen klima aufschläge die noch oben
drauf kommen den leuten wirklich zu
sagen ja da müsst ihr halt weniger
verbrauchen unverschämtheit sagst du
aber natürlich irgendwo ein ehrlicher
satz weil genau das wohin die ja er habe
ich unverschämte preise also wenn ich
mir genau die parteiprogramme von grün
und auch von spd angucke dann gehts ja
nicht unbedingt darum weniger strom zu
verbrauchen da geht es eher darum dass
wir mehr öko strom herstellen und
beispielsweise weniger atomstrom und
braunkohle strom verbrauchen aber den
bundesbürgern jetzt zu sagen verbrauch
doch einfach auch weniger strom das
möchte ich mir wirklich angucken da soll
frau bali doch mal in die wohnzimmer und
in die wohnung derjenigen gehen die
morgens früh aufstehen die hart arbeiten
und denen sie dann sagt stellt auch den
fernseher einfach ein bisschen früher
aus oder macht das licht aus zudem die
kerze an das ist arrogant und
unverschämt
[Musik]